[Music]
we did this like
photo session day very early on and it
was like a test footage shoot with
the full cruella garb in black and white
and she looks so cool and she holds
herself with such
confidence disney went on to show that
test photo
at the disney expo and suddenly that one
image just ignited the entire internet
where people got so excited for this
movie
cruella gets things done stella does not
there's always the question of like how
cognizant is she of her actions is this
a show or is this who she's become
where she's playing corella but then
where does she become corella
and she does an amazing job with playing
with those facets until she finds her
true self within there somewhere
she's got great evil character to get
her teeth into
and she plays it with this combination
of real charm and seductive
wickedness it's just delicious to watch
it really is a story on nature versus
nurture too she was nurtured one way and
her nature
may be different i see it as her coming
to terms
with her nature because as we know
cruella deville
is pretty villainous
and we understand at the end of this
film
she's accepting it rather than fighting
it
anyway mustache
much to avenge revenge and destroy
you